[LAUGHTER]
>> IT'S TIME FOR
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG WARS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
YOUTUBEERS WERE FURIOUS OF THE
NEW COMMENTING SYSTEM INTEGRATED
INTO GOOGLE PLUS IS RUINING
YOUTUBE.
WITH THAT IN MIND TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS RUINAWEBSITE.
YOU'RE GOING TO TAKE
RUINAWEBSITE LIKE DISFIGURED
FACEBOOK OR COLLEGE HUMOR WOULD
BE ANOTHER ONE OR FUNNY OR LADY
DI WOULD BE ANOTHER ONE YOU
COULD GO WITH.
YOU GUYS ...
[LAUGHTER]
YOU GUYS CAN PLAY ALONG AT HOME
BY TWEETING YOUR HASHTAG RUIN A
WEB NIGHT.
>> TAINTED COOL NEWS.
>> FINE.
KOECHNER.
>> SPONGE REPORT.
>> NIKKI.
>> E-BAY HAR.
>> FINE.
JUDD.
>> HAROLD PINTERREST.
>> PENNY G MAIL.
>> IT WILL BE SWEET AND BUTTERY
TO GET THOSE E-MAILS.
YES.
>> HAMAZON.
>> YES THE ONLY WEB SITE WHERE
YOU CAN BUY HAM.
JUDD.
>>
MY MOIST SPACE.
>> I WOULD SAY IT HAS MORE
MEMBERS THAN THE CURRENT
MYSPACE.
NEXT.
>> I AM LBDJ.
[APPLAUSE]
>> NIKKI GLASER.
>> BINGE BUTT.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY MORE YOU WANT
TO THROW IN THERE.
JUDD.
>> E-BAY OF PIGS.
>> BOYS.
>> GHOST STEP DADDY.